along with where he's having with big black bowls. >> That's
not saying that that's real, right? Along with where he's having
with big black bowls. Now, these are >> is a bowl. >> These
are furries. That That could actually be a real thing. No, he
doesn't mean black men. He's We're talking about
>> Okay. Have you ever Have you never seen the thousands
of videos on YouTube and America's Funniest Home videos where
someone falls down and their dog immediately starts humping them?
Is the dog not consenting to some form of contact at that point?
I think I'm just permanently sus and I don't trust any of these
people. And the moment that I say, "Oh yeah, that guy's not a
in a year he will have like 10 children or something just to
humiliate me."
If you guys don't know your movie sucks, that's Adam. This YMS
uh let's take a look at his channel here. Uh, Yms
Yms Yms.
He is a I'd say if you know him or if you if you watch Destiny,
if you're one of the people here who came from the Destiny community,
then you would maybe know Adam as the guy who reviews movies.
He did one of the early episodes of Anything Else or Bridges.
I think Bridges actually. >> Yeah, he did one episode on
um Bridges. It was one of those episodes where it was just uh
him and Destiny. >> Yeah. Yeah. So, he's done that. He's
like a friend of Destiny's big YouTuber, 1.1 million subscribers
who reviews movies. He's a big movie review guy, a media review
guy, right? Yms does really good work. I think I think I've heard
that as well that he is really really like his media critiques
are like really good. He's like got a lot of thought going on.
He's got a lot of experience with the music side of a lot of
movies, right? His stream of Lykan was better. I remember his
stream of Lykan. It was not bad.
It was not too bad. Um, so If you didn't know this, he's been
very, very open about the fact that he is a
Yms just an open, out there, all-in furry. Okay? That's who he
is. That's who he is. That's who he is. That's who he is. That's
who he's been. You know
>> Used to like like Yms, but then he gave Stop making
sense of five out of 10. I don't even know what that is. So,
in any case, YMS is a furry. people rediscover this sometimes
and he tends to make some arguments that don't paint him in a
favorable light. So recently
a slop tuber as we affectionately refer to them named Rob's Media
decided to take a swing at him. Okay, idiot influencers, your
movie sucks. We got this Rob's Media guy, Rob's Media, he does
videos on different influencers. Okay, so two weeks ago he did
Lion Lover. This is uh YMS here. He's done videos on denims.
He's done videos on Casey. He's done videos, I guess, on Chris
Tyson, >> Idubbbz.
He does a lot of um >> Yeah, this guy >> EHD anti-
>> Mike from PA. He hates a lot of people Nick hates. >> Yeah,
he's like anti- Ante Ethan, I would say, is like a lot of the
content he does. >> Oh, okay. >> Yeah. Yeah. I would
say hating people that Nick hates. Also a good description. Okay.
P Media Rob's Media's voice is gay than YMS. That's a weird That's
a weird comment. In any case, okay, he decided to do a hit piece
on
YMS definitely got some weird [__] going on. Okay,
that's just facts.
Got some weird furry [__] going on that people have
a hard time getting a handle on. All right, and this video does
a good job of introducing it. And I'm going to I'm going to have
to control the inner DJer when it comes to some of the dog some
of the arguments. Okay, I'm not even going to go any further
than that. Some of the arguments that go on. Okay, you have like
a
he's he's stretching the limits the utmost limits of the well,
if it doesn't harm you, why are you complaining ideology? Okay,
let's take a look. >> Welcome back to Idiot Influencers.
Today, we'll be covering a beloved movie reviewer here on YouTube
named Adam Johnston, aka Your Movie Sucks. I used to be a fan
of >> Oh, by the way, I should point out this spills over
into like a big feud on Twitter between Nicholas,
YMS, and like a bunch of other commentary YouTubers who are all
pretty pissed off at him. I don't even know if they know what
they're talking about or if they're just following Nick's lead.
It really, I don't know. >> Yeah. I mean, if if you want
me to set it up more,
there are a lot of old takes. There's a lot to criticize about
Adam or if people don't like like degeneracy, there's going to
be a lot to like pull from there and to shun or disavow, yada
yada, right? But it gets really sticky when a bunch of people
don't know what they should be putting in their video, what they
should be censoring or not. And just so much devolves from this.
So so much possible sharing of >> is it or sharing two
kids? >> Were they 18 or might have been sharing two kids?
>> I have two kids basically is like the allegation I think
Adam eventually comes out with. >> We'll get to it though.
>> We will get to it. We'll get to it. Why had a sus Reddit
post about animals years ago that people bring up a lot? Well,
guess what? That's going to be a part of it. Yms up until a few
years ago. And recently, I've decided to look into his now forgotten
controversies, ones that he successfully turned into running
gags within his content. But the more I've delved into them,
the more degenerate and twisted Adam truly seems to be. I'm not
really going to be focusing on his movie reviews themselves,
as many of those controversies are small and overall insignificant,
though a few are funny to me, like when he negatively reviewed
the film Prince of Egypt because he's a hardcore Reddit atheist
who hates all things Christianity. There's also drama involving
him and his former roommate and editor, Mark. Mark kept making
excuses for why he couldn't get work done, leading to Adam having
mental breakdowns over the stress of it all. Around 2017, he
became more open about the fact that he's a furry or a fur fat
as he likes to call it. >> I I I can't really call this
common knowledge, but anyway, I'm a I'm a I'm not joking. I'm
a gigantic fur. I I go to the conventions.
>> I do furry.
>> What the the audio sensor? >> What they just did
for a sensor. I know exactly what he's saying. >> Yeah,
I think it's just about fooling YouTube. It's not really about
or whatever. And so just just the fact >> I can't even
get a without thinking of a half animal, half human cartoon,
that's pretty weird on its own. So I mean, >> is this a
joke or are you >> It's not a joke. I know. I know that
my sarcastic voice sounds exactly like my serious voice. I'm
When I say I'm a fur fat, I I'm not even I'm not even
>> Wait, is this the Charlie podcast? Is this whatever
part is this supposed to be Charlie down here? What is this podcast?
I recognize the podcast, right? It's um what podcast is it? Yeah,
it's the one with um it's not Kai.
I can't
I can't even remember who these people are. Uh anyway, Ka Ka
Ka follows me on Twitter. Um and then Charlie. >> just
referencing the uh the the joke of what people call fries. I
mean, like I'm super gay, too, and I know my voice. >> Yeah.
Well, I don't even know what Swat Cats was. God, please. >> Adam
claims he's attracted to male furries and has a history of going
to furry conventions. In fact, his iconic profile picture is
a cropped image of him next to whatever the this is. This was
taken at Rainfirst 2012. And if that name sounds familiar, you've
most likely seen this internet historian video. Rainfirst became
infamous after his 2015 convention due to the degeneracy of all
the attendees. Multiple assaults were reported. Furries were
illegally hotboxing in their rooms. A flood was started due to
someone loosening a toilet's bolts. 2,000 nitrous oxide canisters
were found in the stairwell and used diapers were being left
on people's cars. Adam went to Rainfirst 2015, claiming >> very
gross. Very gross. >> That none of that actually happened.
He quickly corrects himself by saying it did happen, but it was
all done by a small minority of people. What people don't realize
is that like a lot of the people think the convention got banned
for is not what it actually got banned for. Half of the that
appeared online, the like, ooh, people were leaving diapers in
the stairwells and diapers on cars and like that didn't actually
happen and it was just one guy. It was literally you can trace
it back to one Twitter account.
>> No. Okay, cuz wait, one person has to have like the
longest drawn out
I don't know like irritable bowel syndrome like explosive diarrhea
to be in multiple diapers and leaving them around. >> Guy
filled 80 80 diapers in a weekend. That's crazy.
>> Prolific this guy prolific. >> Either way, all
future rainforest conventions were cancelled due to these incidents.
In 2022, Adam would show off his persona, a feminine horse.
>> In 2022,
say hello to Adam.
This pretty pony is making his debut at BLFC this weekend. >> Wait,
someone is saying that the diapers aren't for >> By the
way, just so we're clear, I don't know what that could possibly
mean. >> I don't want to know what it means, but be clear.
>> We had a bit of an argument about this earlier. You
wanted evidence that he was the one getting. Okay. He's the horse.
He is the female horse.
>> I wanted what evidence? >> Not them. With regards
to the argument he's making about harm later on, but we'll get
to Adam would show off his persona. A feminine horse. Vos is
popping an insane right now. He posts a series of photos in this
suit along with having big black balls. I'm obviously not going
to show any along with having
>> my right now. He >> Hold on. Okay. For a second
I was like, does this thing have a bulge? It's just the tail.
It's just the tail. It's just the tail, guys. >> We're
okay. It's just the tail. We're all right. We're all We're all
good. We're all good. >> He posts a series of photos in
this suit along with where he's having sex with big black bulls.
I'm obviously not going to show any of this. What I will show
you is this infamous tweet from April >> Is that Bert?
>> Yeah, it looks like Bert. Yeah, Bert. >> I'm obviously
not going to show any of this. What I will show you is this infamous
tweet from April 2018.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait. I didn't even catch what this
is.
>> It's It's a cartoon, right? >> Suit along with
where he's having with big black bowls. >> That's not saying
that that's real, right? Along with where he's having with big
black bowls.
Now, these are >> is a bowl. >> These are furries.
That That could actually be a real thing. No, he doesn't mean
black men. He's We're talking about
>> He means literal bulls. >> I'm obviously not going
to show any of this. What I will show you is this infamous tweet
from April 2018. It reads to all of the people.
>> What does what say? >> No, he's about to read
it >> out there that think illustrated and or fictional
depicting illegal activity should be illegal. Why do you not
apply the same logic to films and literature depicting acts of
murder? I don't see how it's different from an ethical standpoint.
It's purposely vague, but it's clear to me and many others that
this is a defense of Lollcon and Shodakon. If you don't know
what that is, it's drawings of children. If this sounds like
a reach, a lot of the top comments are making defenses of this
stuff. And it becomes clear once additional context is added.
Comments, it's victimless imaginary characters. To make it illegal
would literally be thought policing. >> Are making defenses
of this stuff. And it becomes clear once additional context is
added. Only a few days earlier, a massive drama erupted on Frey
Twitter due to some >> He's a lollycon, too. I actually
don't know if he's a lollycon. I don't necessarily think he's
a lollycon. >> He does the defense. >> He has to
defend it for the same reason that his right. He has to make
the exact same arguments for all of his that a lollycon would
make. >> Someone named Tackle Box being exposed for allegedly
enjoying cub. Most furries called this out, but I guess Adam
had a vague post downplaying what happened here. Seeing that
Adam is very well connected to the furry community, it can't
be a coincidence that this is what he's responding to. And if
you still think this is a stretch, Adam was on stream with Mark
defending the idea of drawing,
saying it should be legal. Should animated child be legal? Yes,
it should be. You shouldn't be able to go to jail for drawing
something even if it's like disgusting. And people now I feel
like most people who defend this, most people who stand on business
right here, okay, they don't they won't lean into that label.
They'll go, "Oh, there's a different label I like." It's kind
of weird to just stand on business on that label, the animated
drawn child porn label.
Um, mostly just optically like I I get very wary of anybody who's
just a total like optics bomber. Like if you won't if you won't
try to soften things sometimes for people, I'm just like, "Oh,
you're you're probably like kind of [__] up in a
way that I'm pretty concerned about. There's some weird [__]
going on here." >> Don't agree with it. >> Yeah,
that's like
>> like you can just not look at it if you don't like it.
There's no victim to drawing something. >> Yeah. I I love
it when people think that like an actual baby's been harmed by
drawing one. It's like what are you like mental? I know that
like people get uncomfortable, but like >> Exactly. You
shouldn't jail people for being uncomfortable. >> This
stream clip is currently unlisted. Huh. I wonder why. The only
time I've seen this stuff get brought up significantly is when
Turkey Tom briefly mentioned it. >> And why is your name
Turkey Tom, but you're not a turkey? All right. If you really
wanted to pull this off and brand it right, you'd be a turkey.
>> In mid 2018, Tommy,
>> Oh, well, >> I love the slop tubers who put like
all of the clips in the middle. >> This is like an old
form of slop tuber that most of them don't do this anymore. They
just write like tighter narratives instead of doing like memes
all the >> But a couple of them still just do memes in
between everything. Like all the cuts are memes. >> Lost
video covering Digi Bro where he made a slight jab against Adam.
Adam clapped back with a really angry comment. I love how literally
all took me to comment, "Yep," on one of Digi's videos for you
to basically go, "Hey, did you know that Yms also thinks that
it to a cartoon isn't the same as abusing children? He's a fur
[__] Therefore, arguments that he supports are wrong."
Hilarious. Absolutely hilarious. He then rants about Kiwi Farms,
calling them out for doxing. However, I suspect that he's more
mad at Kiwi Farms for documenting a really creepy habit of his.
On another stream, Adam would defend. >> Yeah, many such
cases. What the I have a stream elements link on Twitch. What
the hell is that? Hold on. I was going to try to link guys. Um,
we got two hours left or sorry, we got 1 hour left on the stream.
So, we are at five subs.
No, we're uh we're
>> we are >> eight subs. Eight subs from another
two hours on the stream, guys. Eight subs from another two hours
on the stream. You might have a hard time donating on kick right
now. So you go through Streamlabs, you go through Stream Ele
or sorry, Streamlabs or Kickbot, either one. Okay. >> Theity
the attraction to animals. He flat out says that people shouldn't
go to jail for having of animals. Seeing that as some form of
bigotry.
If a if a state has animal abuse laws but not zuilia beastiality
laws, that means that if they have sex with an animal and it
is determined that they were abusing the animal or not, you know,
if they if they the animal, if they force the
343, thank you for the primer. Let's go. >> Me and you
were were sunlocked on this this morning.
Yeah, cuz I >> Well, you were doing the the contrarian.
What are the arguments that are going to come out on the other
side? >> I thought he was just making this argument. I
thought he was saying like technically this is a reason these
things exist. Like they have to add beastiality laws because
technically you can't show that an animal is like in distress
or I thought that was like tech, but it's not really what he's
arguing here. I I misunderstood his argument off the bat. >> He's
making a slight >> abuse laws, but not zuilia beast >> that
people shouldn't go to jail for having of animals. seeing that
as some form of bigotry.
>> If a if a state has animal abuse laws but not zuilia
beastiality laws, that means that if they have sex with an animal
and it is determined that they were abusing the animal or not,
you know, if they if they the animal, if they force the animal
and the animal didn't like it, then they would determine that
the animal was being
>> So it he's basically saying these are the reasons. Well,
sorry. He's saying he is saying in essence because he makes this
point in other places that he only thinks it's bad if the animal
is abused,
which is a weird like just a weird line to take. Okay.
It's just it's odd. All right. And we're going to trust me, there's
going to be a lot of other there's going to be other reinforcements
of the same argument coming up. Uh >> I just
to me that is saying, hey, not all with animals is abusive.
And then I think you're a weirdo.
I think you're a weirdo and I think I have to be worried about
everything else that's going to come out of your mouth. >> I
just think Yeah. I just think you could You don't have to die
in that hill. You can just be like, "Yeah, having sex with animals
is bad. You could just do that." >> And I don't even need
you locked up. I don't need you locked up. But I do need to take
you less seriously
and scrutinize maybe your activity and your influence on the
internet. >> Yeah. Yeah. The reason why zuhilia and beastiality
laws exist is because people would be in court over having sex
with an animal
and no one would be able to determine whether or not the animal
was actually abused, which I don't think you should go to jail
if
if there's no evidence whatsoever that the animal was being abused.
Cuz if the animal wasn't
>> what evidence is he looking for? Um >> is it like
um because in kits you can have you have evidence of like tearing
or something like that. Um
>> uh bleeding
>> the big one with humans that comes before the kit even
>> vibration of the vocal cords which produces the sound.
I was right. >> Okay. Yes. Yes. That one where they can
literally talk to you, speak to you. >> Yeah. You do not
get that on uh you don't don't get that with animals. Yeah. >> Yeah.
Obviously. So when he But what he's looking for then is like
well if I use like enough lube then there will be no evidence
of abuse cuz that's what
>> accordingly to other people involved. The reason Diddy
uses so much lube has so much astro whatever Astro >> get
in trouble. Yeah. >> Because with that one person they
had to go to the hospital because Yeah.
>> I could see. Yeah, everyone ignores the other obvious
reason for laws like this. Even if you don't care about the animal,
you want to enforce certain baseline standards because societies
that don't do the that end up being really weird. Okay. Yeah,
sure. I think yeah, obviously you do this to like prevent it
from being society acceptable. >> Fizures, is that how
it's called? Someone off Dave in chat typed it. >> Oh,
absence of fissures. Critical. >> Fissures. Okay. Yeah.
Yeah. >> Yeah. Yeah. which I don't think you should go
to jail if
if there's no evidence whatsoever that the animal was being abused
because if the animal wasn't abused then you're not really helping
anybody. You're just putting somebody in jail cuz you don't like
them cuz you think that what they're doing is gross and you don't
understand them. >> And this isn't the only time Adam has
said stuff like this. >> You're just putting them in jail
cuz you don't like them. That's the animal liked it and and nobody
was hurt and you're just putting them in jail cuz you don't like
them actually. >> Yeah. You're just like this weirdo third
person. You're like a bigot. >> Me and this dog consented
and like you're just you're mad
and you're just putting me in jail because what? You didn't consent?
>> Yeah. And >> who asked? >> Yeah. It's this
is like the the the lack of harm, the absence of harm argument,
right? And it's like, okay,
you've kind of this is like might be the actual case for how
we prove that this is weird or this is wrong. The absence of
harm argument. Like this. You're actually making the case for
us right now. Thank you. All right, there's going to be some
Aiden Ross drum after this. >> He has an extensive history
of playing devil's advocate for obesity. >> Oh, we got
to read these actually. Cherry, you want to read the first post?
>> Oh, yeah. Is the first Oh, the first post is Adam. >> First
post is Adam. >> If anyone wants to have an actual discussion
on the subject, I'm perfectly willing to defend my controversial
opinions. Right now, I'm just seeing a lot of, "Wow, Adam without
any actual constructive debate or discussion." Here's the comment
I just left on the video in case anyone's wondering. Thank you
for linking to the original video in the description so people
can see the full argument, but I do not see why you left out
so much of it. I stand by my controversial opinions. I do not
believe that sex with animals should be Hold on. This is him
saying it should be encouraged, but I am wholeheartedly against
imprisoning those who have had non-abusive relations
with animals. To say that there is such a thing
that there is no such thing is incredibly ignorant and illogical.
Objective reasoning matters more to me than emotional gut responses.
I do not believe in putting innocent people in jail just because.
Ew. Gross. Uh, I'll be the other guy. How can an animal provide
meaningful consent to a human? >> In the same way that
the animal can provide meaningful consent to another animal,
most communication between animals is non-verbal. Have you ever
been to Have you ever seen the thousands of videos on YouTube
and America's
>> Hold on. Oh, shoot. Hold on. I I wanted to I don't know
why I paused it as if that was going to pause you. >> I
just had to point out that he's actually making the argument
that the dog gives him a look.
>> The dog. >> The dog gave me the look. Okay. There's
a look. Yeah. >> Or a bark. >> It's weird. It's >> a
happy bark. >> Sorry, I keep hitting play as if he was
going to read it. He's not reading it.
>> Can you from where you >> Okay. Have you ever
Have you never seen the thousands of videos on YouTube and America's
Funniest Home videos where someone falls down and their dog immediately
starts humping them? Is a dog not consenting to some form of
contact at that point? I get that we live in a world where most
people's interaction with animals are are ones that have had
their balls surgically removed without their consent, of course,
but animals with drives clearly don't give a [__]
about their
about what they're and are just doing whatever feels good to
them. >> Wow. That is not consent. Usually, animals don't
provide consent. How can they communicate that meaningfully?
If a 12-year-old starts humping you because he's horny, does
that mean it's okay because he is providing consent? No. There
are laws to protect the animal. Animals can't defend themselves
the way a human can. I understand that there is no law against
farming animals for food or whatever. And I do think that is
wrong. So yeah, we'll get into like the vegan arguments on this,
but this is another good point is animals have an extremely diminished
capacity to consent. You know who else does? >> White Oh,
>> children have a diminished capacity to consent. I >> was
going to say white women. It >> you you can't argue that
if the child tries to consent with you and you're fine with it,
that that is consent and that is okay. Yeah, that is a good point
by this person.
>> It's Yeah, it's just it's some baffling >> And
I also
taking advantage of the nature of the dog like you know that
the dog if you just do this the dog is going to want to hump
you and feel good. You are a pervert. There's something the wrong
with you if you will like stay still to let the dog do what it's
going to do
>> You got some sort of sick perversion. >> You got
some weird [__] going on, man. You a weird guy. You're
like one step away from full psycho to me. >> A weird guy.
Okay, buddy. You a weird guy. Yeah. Yeah, I agree. All right,
let's uh let's continue on here. >> Get this guy off the
title and all. >> We are actually just hitting play. >> He's
written multi par.
>> Never mind. We're not just hitting play. I'll read this
one. >> Uh thank you for linking to the original video
in the description so people can see the full argument, but I
do not see why you left out so much so much of it. I stand by
my controversial opinions. I do not believe that sex with animals
should be encouraged, but I am wholeheartedly against imprisoning.
Oh, this is the same post, right? This is >> Okay. And
then growling mic says
non-abusive relations with animals. How can you assert that there
is no way that an animal can consent to it relationship with
a human being? >> Plus growling mic one. If an animal can't
consent to a be to a human being, then an animal can't consent
to another animal. By that logic, an animal also can't consent
to literally anything else you do to it. Animals don't consent
to being domesticated, having their genitals surgically removed,
eating the same food every day forever, etc. If you are against
all forms of contact between humans and animals, then we should
all rally against farmers, breeders, and all other legal forms
of contact with animals. The jackass crew jerked off a horse
for comedic effect in Jackass 3. Tom Green did the same thing
in Freddy Gotfinger. Should they be jailed? At least be consistent.
>> This is a debate. >> Yeah, this is a this is actual
debate
This is very, very weird [__] I don't know.
Does this just prove having uh proximity to Destiny is a cognto
hazard a little bit? Yeah. No, actually, unironically, yes. >> Do
you think that he
is formed the way that he is from watching Destiny debates or
does Destiny attract
>> these types of people? >> Yeah, Destiny filters
in weirdos. >> Yeah, I think the weirdos are like flies
or like moths attracted to like the light that he shines. >> Yeah,
absolutely. Oh, here's somebody who can make my dog arguments
for me. Thank you. >> Thank you, sir. >> Paragraph
long essays through Reddit and YouTube comments trying to restate
his position whenever anyone makes fun of him for it. It's kind
of like the whole leftist meme trend where he turned everybody
away because he included too many words. I won't read all of
these for time's sake, but feel free to pause if you want to
analyze these walls of text. This clearly became a soft spot
to Adam as he'd get pitched whenever anyone joked about his >> think
it would be easier to just give a yes or no answer to a yes or
no question. Do you condone Zuilia? I don't understand why it's
so difficult to take a hard stance on this either way. I don't
want to see a dissertation. It's just a yes or no question that
requires a yes or no answer. Do you want to [__]
dogs? Yes or no? Yes or no? Do you want to [__] dogs?
Do you want to [__] dogs? Dude, turns out Pisco couldn't
answer this question either. What the [__] When Matan
hit Pisco with this question, did you that dog and Pisco couldn't
answer it? What is happening in this world? How is that a hard
question? >> Has Pisco since answered that? Because he's
given a lot of thought about, oh yeah, that was a bad strategy.
Have he has he said, "No, I don't have >> I don't know,
but it would be funny to just ask him. Um, I'll keep that in
mind if I if I'm ever if I'm ever in a combo with Pisco again,
I'll keep that in >> You and you guys do not go starting
to ask him, okay? That's jarring. Can I do a Matan accent? So,
do you dogs? Do you [__] Do you dogs? I don't remember
what Matan said exactly to him. Okay. >> No, we're not
saying [__] the dog. It's
>> it's the >> It's just funny that the the question
the question caught him off guard. He couldn't answer it. It
was just uh >> It was a It was a joke. Okay.
Anyway, Adam, this guy says, "Can you give me a yes or no answer?"
It was the combination of the the Zufilia question and the yes
or no thing. Put me under Pisco. Okay. No other reason to believe
anything weird is happening there. Okay. An unkindness. This
is >> Well, also hold on
because I'm takenback by so many people in this space. I'm not
gonna say Pisco hasn't dog until I hear him say it.
>> Yeah, that's what I'm going with. >> Pisco seems
I've done this with other people in other things before. Pisco
seems I have no reason to assume or suspect that Pisco a dog
more than basically anybody else who's ever been morally confounded
by somebody like Matan. Not morally like uh like confounded by
somebody like Matan. Okay. Lots of people get confused by Maton.
He was confused. I have no reason to believe he's any more likely
to have [__] a dog than anybody else in that. >> But
I I believe that Maton 100% has or thinks about a dog >> probably.
Yeah. Yes. Guy's a weirdo. >> All right. This is YMS's
next post. If you don't believe that every single farmer, animal
breeder, Tom Green, and the jackass crew belong in jail, then
you don't then you condone attacks on animals. There is no meaningful
difference to the animal whether or not a human being is getting
off on this act. Yet the sole factor is yet that is the sole
factor people like you use to determine the act the morality
of the act. It's really not complicated to understand that if
there is no yes or no answer to whether or not people condone
sorry it's really not complicated to understand that there is
no yes or no answer to whether or not people condone acts between
humans and animals. If you believe there is, you're lying to
yourself. You simply are not willing to face the fact that you
and everyone else on this planet currently condones interactions
between humans and animals so long as the human isn't getting
off to it. See, there's no no harm. Hey, you you let us rap animals
all the time. You literally let us animals all the time, but
if I get off if I get a now it's now it's wrong. That's Adam's
argument. Okay. Hey, you let this cow get to have like more calves
to make more beef for your farm, but if I jerk off to that, I'm
the weirdo.
It is like, "Yeah, Adam, you're the weirdo. You're wrong. Adam,
yes, Adam, stop. Stop. For the love of God, man. Please."
>> No.
This is disgusting. I think he's So, part of this has to do with
what is it? They have to like put their hands inside the ass
of cows or horses to relieve them or something. >> Oh,
that's probably >> for farming. >> There's a whole
bunch of stuff like that. Yeah. You just know that this guy watches
farmer videos to get off. >> Well, he says he's not a zoo
pile. >> He says it. He says it, but he's probably out
there reading the
Uh, Indians gang a goat to death and he's thinking, "Finally,
the culture is moving my way. Maybe I'll go to India." >> Somebody
find me Adam's H1B position. Okay. Is he all for Is he for like
doubling, tripling, quadrupling the number of H-1Bs? He's like,
"Oh, we'll get them. We'll get the votes eventually. We'll get
him here.
Oh boy.
Uh, wait one second. Here's an analogy. I knew a guy from high
school who talked to an army recruiter and then and when asked
why he wanted to join, he said, "I want to kill people." And
they didn't let him join. Until he tried again a year later,
but that's not the point. Oh, like if you give a [__]
up reason, they're like, "Oh, actually, no, that'd be really
Yeah. >> Oh, get the out of here. Adam is
>> From the same place Lauren Southern is. There's what
the >> JJ maka >> what the is in the water here.
>> Not here
anyway.
No. Nope. Nope. Nope. >> Okay. Okay. Keep going. Keep going.
>> Uh my belief is that an act Oh, sorry. This is the next
part. My belief that an act causing harm to an animal is wrong
regardless of whether it's or not. Okay. So, so you can immediately
go to
a hypothetical where farming, like factory farming and [__]
doesn't exist, where everybody's vegan, where none of this stuff
is done to animals at all. Now, make your argument for why you
get to [__] that pig. Okay, that's what he needs
to do cuz he's trying to morally confound people on all the vegan
questions, but he's not even nobody's he's not even arguing that
he thinks um like that stuff's okay or that he could eat meat.
He's like, "No, no, no. I think all animal cruelty is wrong."
It's like, okay, so pretend there is no other animal cruelty.
Now tell me why you get to that dog, cuz I I I don't get it.
I don't think it's right. So he he goes on, your belief is that
the the harm uh being placed on an animal is that the only morally
wrong instances, sorry, your belief is that harm being placed
on an animal is that the only morally wrong instances are ones
where humans are getting off on the act.
The fact that you be uh you people have convinced yourself that
your position is the moral high ground here is insane. I hope
you actually think about subjects that you have strong emotional
feelings on in the future. The world isn't black and white. The
world is made a worse place from people like yourself who insist
it is.
listen, Adam, why do you have strong emotional feelings on this?
>> Uh, I know why he does. >> he's got romantic feelings
on this. That's the problem. >> I just I wish I didn't
have to hear all of this uh pseudo intellectual crap. Just tell
me what you want to do. Tell me what you want to
and then and then I'll decide if this is weird or not. Don't
walk me down this logical tree that you think will help me just
agree to let you that horse. Just tell me you want to that horse.
>> Yeah. Uh hold on. Um get Clemen on here. He thinks if
we eat animals, we should be able to them. Um this is like the
same vegan argument. I don't think moral consistency is the highest
virtue we have in the world, right? Like just because those are
incompatible positions doesn't mean you should because you're
violating one you should have to let people violate the other.
Doesn't really mean that right. And even from like a bio uh like
a biological perspective for humans like
social hold on donated three >> donated $3 nerd face emoji
index pointing at the viewer emoji. Actually sleeping with the
animal isn't the worst possible outcome. >> It's it's not.
Um, so we have this like evolved social norm from needing to
eat meat, from being like uh omnivores, right? Needing to eat
meat. >> Yeah. To survive. Like that's one of the things
you could eat to survive. So we don't think eating animals is
bad, but you didn't need to animals to survive. There's no social
norm there, right? Later on, we'll hear an argument from somebody
and and this Rob's media guy is like five IQ. So he goes, "Actually,
yeah, that's a good point. You do need to eat meat to survive."
It's like, "No, you don't." fight. >> Stop with this hypocrisy
and explain to me right now you need to get by a horse because
you're so depressed without horse or something.
>> Like make your actual argument. Stop hiding behind this
debate pervertry. >> Yeah. Gets harder and harder to listen
to the stream on speakers shaking my head. Whoa. Because of the
topic. I thought this was an audio issue, but it's the topic.
I got it. Yeah. Yeah. >> Listen, this is going to be a
weird one. Okay. But I wanted to do YMS stuff cuz >> I
feel like this could keep going places. It doesn't seem like
either side has put >> has put the uh what do you call
it? The
>> Did Queman actually want to join or were they just um
>> Oh, somebody was saying get on. Everybody makes that
argument. Everybody who's ever watched a Destiny stream and Queman
watched a lot of Destiny streams.
>> Knows the arguments for like the veganism like, "Oh,
you animals so you should not have any problem killing animals
thing, right?"
>> Sorry. you kill animals, so you shouldn't have any problem
with animals thing. Everybody knows that argument. Everybody
can make that argument. >> Oh, the argument comes up in
Adam's >> Yeah. All it requires is like the the do no harm
principle being like important there, right? And and then the
whole like, well, you have to stay consistent in terms of the
harm.
Yeah. I very cute. I think a lot of people don't even really
believe that. They just know that's the argument. Like I know
that's the argument, but it's uh it's goofy. I I think it's it's
probably just goofy. Um anyway, we Oh, I wasn't done with this
post. Hold on. Uh, the fact that you
the world isn't black and white and the world is made a worse
place from people like you who insist it is. Here's a question
for you. Yes or no? Do you do farmers and animal breeders belong
in jail? Yes or no? Are they as bad as other human beings performing
identical acts on a on an animal with the only difference being
the human receiving gratification from said in identical act?
Okay. So basically if I were to jerk off to this or if I were
to put a dick in something my dick in something here is it worse?
Please answer those uh since you think the world is so simple.
>> Well I also >> told you >> that's also not
difficult. I think a lot of there were a lot of problems people
had with farming.
I think it's very popular to have like a more humane form of
farming. And I think a lot of people don't like what the practices
of breeding animals
like the way that they would get um fast horses, right? They
would like collect salmon and they would like force breed them.
Same with >> you don't get faster horses. You can do it
naturally, but you could just >> Yeah. Yeah. >> You
would just pick like winners and stuff like that.
>> Yeah. We treat animals badly. We do. Ask yourself community
workshop this vegan argument. Yeah. Yeah. >> Farming. That's
what it's called. Yeah. >> Says, "The funniest instance
of this is when Adam started an argument."
>> This is his argument with null. Okay. Which side do
you want of this?
>> I'm going to need it to be bigger. I will be null. >> Here.
I can uh You want to be null? >> Okay. One second. I'll
I'll send you this thing
Discord and you can like open it and have it be >> Oh,
animal husbandry.
>> That's what it's called. >> Okay, Adam. This is
This looks like YouTube replies, right? getting so triggered
over an opinion you disagree with that uh you disagree with that
you lump them in with and animal abusers. That's some SJW level
[__] if I've ever seen it. I'm sorry you dislike
my opinions on moral philosophy, but treating this as anything
more than that is just nonsense. I don't see it as any different
than my opinion on abortion, assistance, or drug legalization.
Each of those topics have huge moral implications associated
with them, but obviously no one's obsessing about any of those
because this is all about trying to paint me as some sort of
animal abuser. Sorry to break it to you, but I don't own a dog
and I have no interest in real animals. The anthro animals I'm
attracted to are lions anyway. So, good luck trying to convince
people I those. Anyways, this is just I obviously condemn the
actions of animal abusers featured in this video. It's disgusting.
Attempting to lump me in with them because you're upset over
my wrong think is disgusting, too, though. >> You said
something incredibly stupid and indefensible.
What Reuben did was obviously worse than just jerking off your
dog because it started humping you or whatever you were trying
to say is initiating is initiation of consensual sex between
animals and humans, but it's still beastiality and it's still
damaging to the animals to have a sexual relationship with what
sounds but with what should be taking care of them. I'm not trying
to hang you over wrong thinking. Uh, but it's fair to say your
fandom is fundamentally about animals when all the community
leaders seem to be apologists for animals. And yes, whether you
accept that mantle or not, you are a community leader and one
of the most high-profile furries in the entire world at this
point. You need to stop trying to defend this. I was made aware
after this stream that your position on consensual beiality allegedly
put a strain on your relationship with Mark to the point where
you cried when he refused to back you up on it. Whether it's
true or not, it's clearly something that is not normal that even
people who really like you think is not normal, which shouldn't
be a pos shouldn't be a position you're willing to die on a hill
or uh I like your stuff, dude. I've listened to every YMS at
least a dozen times as ambiance while doing work and I just wish
you'd taken L on this and reconsider.
>> Wow. So, he got into a big fight with >> with
null, the owner of Kiwi Farm. I think Telstar is blowing him
up on uh on >> after he uploaded a video in late 2018 talking
about the Zusadist Wolf. In that video, he makes the claim that
Adam is part of the growing normalization for [__]
dogs. Thank you for linking to the original video in the description
so people can see the full argument, but I see why you left out
so much of it. I stand by my controversial opinion. So, even
when he gets called out for this, he stands by it. I do not believe
that sex with animals should be encouraged. But I am wholeheartedly
against those against imprisoning those who have had
relations with animal. To say there is no such thing is incredibly
ignorant and illogical. Objective reasoning matters more to me
than emotional gut responses. I do not believe putting innocent
people in jail because ew, gross.
How can an animal provide meaningful consent to a human in the
same way that an animal can provide meaning meaningful consent
to another animal?
>> This is uh null, the owner of Kiwi Farms right here.
This null.
>> Most communications between animals are nonverbal.
Have you ever seen the thousands of videos on YouTube and America's
Funniest Home videos where someone falls down and their dog immediately
starts humping them? Is the dog not consenting to some form of
contact at that point? I get that. We live in a world where most
people's interactions with animals are only ones uh that have
had their balls surgically removed without their consent, of
course. But animals with drives clearly don't give a [__]
about what they and are just doing when they reflect them. Adam
typed out one of his essays saying he isn't actually attracted
to animals and is instead attracted to anthropomorphic lions.
He also spends much of this argument claiming he's not trying
to defend beastiality. >> Bro, do we do we read all of
this?
This is a lot. There's a whole heck of a lot. Do we have to?
>> we definitely don't have to. But >> no, we skip
>> fake lions. >> Oh, wait. Is that also null? >> Yeah,
it's it's >> it's why mess and null arguing the whole
>> Yo, soapbox Society. Thank for the five gifted. That
puts us at what? 30 41
47.
We're about two subs away. Two subs away from another hour on
the or sorry, two more hours on the stream, guys. Two subs. Can
we get those two subs in? We have the two hours of the stream.
Let's >> He also spends much of this argument claiming
he's not trying to defend beastiality, but is instead arguing
against general societal hypocrisies. To him, it's when people
feain outrage over dogs and not horse racing and factory farming.
You you go to some of those like Twitter threads of the ones
being like,
"You must rem never forget that this man said that said that
people shouldn't go to jail for having sex with animals." And
then they leave out the part where I said, "Well, only if it's
if there's literally no measurable harm or distress placed on
the animal, which would make it literally less harmful than the
entire farming industry." He
It's so funny how he has to like he has to really soften that
for people, right? Only if there's no visible. No, just say only
if the animal doesn't like it. >> I'm sorry, but you're
you're only supposed to do that when the thing that people said
about you
was actually wild. Like so out of context or you have like a
gotcha in response. >> I feel like he doesn't. >> This
guy says that I want to [__] animals, but I only
want to [__] animals when they like it. >> He
left out the part where I said they have to like it. I'm thinking
I didn't need to hear that part. I'm feeling the same type of
way. >> If they don't enjoy it, then I don't want to animals.
What What is so hard to understand about that?
>> Listen, I I know that he's like trying to be logical.
He's trying to do it from like a thought experiment.
>> I don't know.
>> We'll see. >> One of his arguments was, "Well,
buddy, no. I'm attracted to lions, so actually you have nothing
to worry about with
>> Yeah. Um,
listen.
Lions can be tranquilized. Okay. Find find Oh, it's a I was gonna
say some somebody figure out if the local zoo has had any problems
with their lions like sleeping all day. Okay. >> Oh jeez.
>> I think he lives in Canada. So, I think that would actually
fall to me and I'm not going to actually do that cuz I never
advocate going to anybody's real life or anything around them
to find out that. So, unfortunately the the joke has to die there.
So, >> we'll never figure it out. But I don't I don't trust
that. I keep seeing these responses all the time now where people
are like, it's like, do you animals? And he's like, I would be
attracted to lions. How would that even work? And it's like,
>> why don't you just say no? Could you say >> Just
say no. Just say no. I've never done that. I will never do that.
That would be so much easier.
>> Anyway, the entire breeding industry
turns out if the person you're is asleep, no
visible distress or pain there. Well, maybe pain, but sorry.
I was trying to recreate his >> right things that people
are already okay with.
>> nothing steal out of here. >> Literally less harmful
than the entire farming industry, the entire breeding
right? Things that people are already okay with. But no, of course,
you don't you don't apply you don't apply that same logic to
people in those industries. You don't you don't go to people
who are like farmers
or have have ever been to like a horse race. so much more abusive
than the examples I'm talking about. You don't you don't apply
that same level of criticism to them. I think you're full of
>> Oh my god. >> I think these people are so funny.
>> If this type of argument sounds familiar, it's exactly
what Vosch does. Vos has an extensive history of playing devil's
advocate for and Molly Con, arguing that people shouldn't be
outraged about it because children are being used to make chocolate
and the clothes we're wearing right now. Both are using whataboutism
to distract people from the fact that they're being apologists
for immoral behavior. Null pretty easily defeated Adam's argument
by stating, "We eat meat because we need to eat to survive. We
inciminate horses and cattle artificially because we are selectively
breeding them for some purpose." There is no situation in which
a person needs to give a dog a [__] And from what
I've shown, that is something of biological risk for the human
and psychological damage for the animal. By the way,
I don't know which person that was. That's what I'm saying. You
need to come out. You stop doing the hypocrisy.
Come >> and tell people I need to suck this horse off.
Otherwise, I'm going to be depressed and kill myself. Make an
actual argument for why you need to normalize doing this. >> I'm
going to say it. Okay. If you have a behavior that's like really
far outside of social norm, you need to tell me there's a benefit.
There has to be a benefit to society. Not just you, not just
for a fetish. There actually has to be a benefit of some kind.
You want to do something like that, have a benefit. If it's just
because, well, you can't prove that I harm this animal by sucking
it. Well, you don't suck the dog's dick. Okay. Do not suck the
dog's dick. >> I don't even think you have to. >> No.
Okay. Don't make Well, for me personally, I don't want you to
make up a societal benefit because I promise you, your kink is
not going to help the world. But you need to explain to me why
you need to be able to do your kink. Why are you so
like we understand that there are certain people where they have
no attraction to anything but what they're not allowed to be
attracted to, right?
Just come out and admit it. You want to blow that horse because
everyone's telling you not to. That's it. >> You have some
deviency in you and
>> There's literally no other reason. You have no idea
why you want to blow that force. You have no idea why you're
attracted to lions. That thing should kill you. You have no idea
except for people told you no, you can't. >> Um,
it's what do you call it? I
>> Yeah, I don't know. It's like there's something along
those lines. There's
I always get like concerned when people don't understand or can't
fathom why people are mad at them or when they're like
when they're like uh what's the word? Oh, there's a word for
it. When they're
indignant. when they're indignant about like this thing like
you are wrong. You're like a bigot for like making this when
it's like something clearly that society like wrong and they're
like continually talking about it. This happened with food shops
when they talked about lolli and like they just didn't I don't
know if they didn't get everybody well they just didn't get how
like everybody they talked about it and it's like dude if you
can't understand what the social contract is if you don't understand
how other people are going to react >> you scare me cuz
like that makes me think that you like you never thought about
this that you can't read other people's emotions or like or like
you don't understand how >> like you don't understand how
to play well with others like you're so poorly socialized I don't
trust you around like >> I have such I have such a deep
distrust distrust of people that I see someone behave like that
and I think you want me to be disgusted. You want your goal is
to repulse me right now. Your goal is to be
um I I don't know
is to cause me to be upset with you. You want to be yelled at.
You want to be like you want that outcome. I don't think you're
naive. I don't think you you're you're blind to how people will
receive that. think you're exactly looking for that
That's part of the enjoyment.
>> Yeah. When they're when they're like that. Yeah, I could
see that, too. >> It's it's one of the two. And one is
like, okay, you you literally One is like you can't you're unaware.
This is like both sides of the the harm coin with regards to
when people So, I remember when I can't I can't remember which
art tuber or which um Artcom
YouTuber it was. Birdie. It was like the birdie and there was
one other person involved. Whatever those people were, those
weird people. And it's like in that case, I remember reading
the messages and being like, "Oh, I don't think this person like
even realizes that they might be harming a kid." But they are
harming a kid. It's not Jar. It's not Kumo. It's the actual person
who is in trouble. Um,
>> are we talking about the person around Mr. Beast?
>> No, no, no. It's our community. Um, >> oh, our
community. >> Art
art. art community. >> So, someone around uh >> Did
Becket cover them? >> Yeah. Yeah. It's like Beckett's >> Oh,
damn. >> But um whatever whatever those people were. It's
like you could tell the person wasn't really trying to um
like they weren't they they're probably just weird and they didn't
understand like what was going wrong. But it's like not seeing
the harm doesn't mean you shouldn't be punished. It's like unfortunately
there are people who can't see the harm they're doing and they're
they're not good. And then there's people who get off to that
and it's like oh you are probably worse actually.
You are worse because the people who get off to it are the reason
why other people are confused on whether or not there's harm
involved when they reproduce that.
>> it was Ciney. It was Ciney was the person who I couldn't
remember. Yeah, thank you. Time for pigs. It was Ciney. >> It
was like the main person. That's who I couldn't remember. Anyway,
>> way this conversation would go on for multiple days.
To give null some criticism, he shouldn't have even tried engaging
with this guy. Adam is never going to change his position. >> That's
Adam. That's why I was like, "Oh, I don't even recognize like
I didn't realize this was Adam." I was like, "That must be him."
But like he looked like way skinny. He looked way different when
he was uh skinnier. >> No should have just called him a
dog and left it at that. And this isn't stuff of the past. As
recent as a year ago, Adam is still on Reddit arguing about beastiality.
It's as recent as a year ago. Adam is still on the >> issue
with the argument around consent is that everyone seems to conflate
consent with informed consent, which obviously animals are not
capable of. Whatever consent animals experience is obviously
not the same standard that we apply to humans. So the argument
does not apply. >> There is no >> wait it would apply
to some standard of humans. Animals do have like the level of
intelligence to understand like
and unfortunately for you it doesn't make it better because the
level of consent that you're arguing for in like animals that's
like a three-year-old child in a lot of cases like like you are
arguing for some crazy >> on Reddit arguing about beastiality.
It's a repetitive cycle for him. This stuff would resurface from
time to time. Most notably in spring of 2020 when he defended
Idubbbz's controversy in a nutshell. The myth of consensuals.
I consent. I consent. I don't. >> Isn't there somebody
you forgot to ask? Idubbbz controversy.
>> Wait, what? >> Idubbbz and Ana during the Only
Fans controversy. And yes, these guys are
>> Wait, what was wrong with Idubbbz and Ana during the
Only Fans controversy? Wait, what what was the consent issue
There was a consent issue there. >> I have no idea.
Is this having to do with people claiming Idubbbz was?
>> I No, I think it's like they are okay with this and
yeah, other people were not okay with the relationship. It's
not literal consent. It's like, oh, they're okay with the relationship
and other people aren't. >> I don't think that's how that
meme's supposed to work. >> Well, no, you can do it that
way, but it's uh it's just a little weird. Sorry. I I assume
because that I assume that's where this robs in Ana during the
only fans controversy. And yes, these guys are friends. How shocking.
People posted memes mocking his beastiality takes leading Adam
to talk about >> Hold on. Uh Marva dude, thank for the
gifted sub, guys. One sub away from another two hours on the
stream. Sorry, that meme was funny. >> Let's go. >> No,
Adam, I don't want I don't want to leave me alone, you degenerate.
>> Okay, it wasn't that funny, actually. But it's a screaming
lion. Okay, that lion looks to be in distress. Adam would never
[__] with that lion. It's in distress. Okay. >> And
memes, mocking his beastiality takes, leading Adam to talk about
it on stream for over an hour. He blames the >> Oh, also,
now that Kick's back, I'm going to go ahead shut it down on uh
on Twitch and go back to kick. Okay, we'll see you guys there
in a little bit.
>> Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye.
There we go. All right. >> Still existing. People being
>> Oh, hold on. I should give people like two minutes to
switch over.
give me a rope and bomb me.
>> Okay, Spruce Willis with a gifted sub. And that gets
us two hours on the stream. Let's go. Gives us all the time to
finish. Trust me, we might even need more than two hours because
we have um what is it going what's going on with YMS here? He
did an hour and 45 minute response to these videos. >> Responds
to this. He did like almost a two-hour response explaining how
he lays out all of his his like meta ethics and [__]
Okay. >> He was being very consistent. >> And it's
so great because after he does his response video, he has several
back and forths.
Well, a couple back and forths with Nicholas Yorio
because Nick has a lot of opinions without watching the video.
Imagine putting an e putting an effort to do almost a 2-hour
video and your opposers aren't even going to watch it before
they criticize you. That's always funny to me. I think I think
Nick should keep doing that. >> Yeah, I think Nick should
consider whether or not he should criticize a video at all before
watching the whole >> No, I think you should never watch
the video. Just speak your truth. >> Oh, I was just saying
that I remember him giving people [__] for not watching
a video before criticizing something. >> to talk about
it on stream for over an hour. He blames the discourse still
existing on people being terminally online, which is ironic as
hell since he's the one constantly talking about it on Reddit.
>> Like a lot of these people are just
Like holy,
like go outside or something like the world is not Twitter. >> He
also expands on his previous what aboutism style arguments by
saying it was always about moral consistency and not beastiality,
even though he can literally use anything else to demonstrate
this. And then people come out against some guy that like sucked
an animal or something. It's like, okay,
no, it's still it's not even about he he can't even make this
argument because he's not doing the same thing vegans are. Vegans
try to gross you out with beastiality to make you understand
why you should be a vegan. He's trying to he's trying to gross
you out with being a vegan so you'll let him dogs. So you let
people around him dogs. I don't know if he dogs actually, but
like that's what it's like the opposite, right? Like he's trying
to gross you out with
Oh, actually, yeah. Well, I am morally inconsistent. You're right.
We should we should let these people suck dogs off. That's totally
that's totally fine.
>> And it's like that's just an argument that stands on
its own. That doesn't have to go with any of the other stuff
that people are okay with harm being >> Is he a vegan?
>> He almost certainly is. Yeah. Based on every argument
he's made, he's almost certainly a vegan. But >> how funny
would it be if he's not a vegan? I remember. Wait, I remember
him and Lykan. Him and Lyken ate steak together, didn't they?
Or was it just Lyan having the steak? I could have sworn Lykan
did a podcast with him and he had whiskey and then Lykan had
a big steak he pulled out and he was like cutting slices off
of it and eating. But I can't remember if animated or not. >> Oh,
that's probably on that's almost certainly on the Ly and Cooks
channel, isn't it? Hold on. Is that what you're looking for?
>> Yeah. What was his channel? >> Liking Cooks. It's
still there.
videos, lives. We got a live with YMS. We got a live with YMS.
Come on. Come on. Here it is. Live. Six and a half hours with
YMS live.
Look at this. Look at what they got here. They got beef. They
got >> Oh, wait. No, no, no. I see. This will be his vegan
he made for Adam, right? >> Yeah. Game. >> I think
it'll be a different one where they uh >> with the Pinocchio.
>> One's probably my favorite. >> I'm asking. That's
what I have to find >> They usually talk about it. I'm
thinking of the other one. And the other one was with Ryan McBth.
I think he has uh he pulls out some steak or something.
>> I could have sworn he had he has one of these videos
where he's got like a big steak he pulls out and they're just
eating like big >> that would have been with that could
have been with Ryan McBth. That dude looks like he >> he
drinks a lot. So >> yeah, he does. I don't Now I don't
recall, but >> I'm going to look it up. You can >> If
I find it, I'll let you know. >> Continue. We continue.
>> You're being a [__] >> Oh, hold on.
Hold on. Billy Joe Boucher
got a link here. What is this >> killer Star Wars show?
It's not like the other ones. >> Oh, yeah. No, >> I
did remember it. Thank you, Billy Joe
>> That is a bunch of steak that he is eating right now.
>> Star Wars. >> So, he's not that I'm sorry. That
actually makes this so funny.
>> And he's doing the vegan arguments.
>> That he's >> You should be against You should
be against uh animal harm. Okay. I'm not >> animal harm.
Like, oh my goodness, you guys are such hypocrites. Here I am
chewing on a steak thinking about horse wanting to lion. This
is this is debate
>> Uh, it is. Has he had some new transition into this
belief? No. Like 10 years ago, he was still a furry. He was still
doing this stuff. That's not true.
Which like I
>> I don't even necessarily have anything against furries.
Okay, we got some okay furries in this Whoops. Not this one.
I have everything against furries right >> hypocrite. That's
stupid. Like that's my
>> It's not about like just
it's it's more about moral consistency than anything
>> I just think I think people are stupid. Earlier in the
stream, he chastises people who he claims are morally grandstanding
over the topic, adding on that it's immoral to judge someone
based on philosophical disagreements.
Like the the entire concept
of rallying against me for this position,
the entire concept of doing that is
to basically say, "Hey, we are the arbiters of morality. That
is clearly immoral and we all need to band together to reassure
ourselves of what morality is. We are moral. He is not. Let's
all agree on that. Let's, you know, be angry about it or whatever,
right? It's It's coming from a uh moral superiority kind of perspective,
right?
>> The ultimate irony in that. What do you think it's coming
from?
>> I It's a I'm not as weird as you. That doesn't make
me more nor like more moral. I don't think I'm a more moral person
than you. I just think that I am maybe not a weirdo who talks
about wanting to fly in on the internet.
Um, so the classic response to this would be if somebody Do you
want me to >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Uh, the classic response
would be, "Okay, well now I'm like a hardcore regressive Muslim
and I think being gay is the grossest thing in the world.
Can I kick people out of my country? Can I >> Oh, I don't
want to kick you out. >> Sorry. Can I do whatever you want
done to Adam? Can I make it totally illegal to engage in that
behavior?"
>> I I haven't made it illegal to engage in Adam's behavior.
>> Oh, okay. >> Right. I think that he should be
>> I think if you if you have such weird proclivities and
you don't take action on them, you just you think about them
and you want everyone to know that you think about a lion.
>> Stop being a debate pervert and just take your you want
to be publicly
>> Just let me do that without >> you told us about
this if you didn't >> pseudo intellectual.
>> Yeah, that's fair. Oh, fair enough. I would have thought
you wanted I would have thought you wanted laws protecting the
dogs, but >> me laws protect
I personally think until you
I mean if you have proof that he a dog I think that's abuse.
>> Yeah, true. >> Yeah, but if I I can't do anything
about thought crimes. I don't think I can do anything about drawings.
>> I sorry I got sent a meme. >> Is this the back
view of the paragon dancing like Nessie thing? >> What
is that? Is that what that's supposed to be? Hold on. >> I'm
not okay with gay people being bullied. But unfortunately, there
are people in this world who are homophobic,
right? That's uh
so long as they're not getting discriminated against. >> It's
like the back.
It's like the back.
What the That was a That's a weird That's a deep cut and it's
weird. So, you're fine with gays being bullied then?
the as a as a Christian, I get bullied a lot for recently finding
my faith. I can't
That's just what's going to happen on the internet. People find
out what you are or what you care about and they want to harass
you for it. >> That's true. People suck.
This just in. People are mean sometimes. >> Yeah. People
>> I prefer when people suck than when people suck horse.
her words were never spoken. That is that
I believe it's incredibly immoral to completely write someone
off as a person entirely based off of a philosophical disagreement.
Like would would that not also constitute these same people applying
that to thems
you just want to cancel me over my philosophical beliefs? >> There's
going to be like a modern version. Who was it that did the three
things will lead to someone like proof that someone's a psychopath
or a sociopath or something which is animal cruelty, wetting
the bed, and what else is what? Oh, pyromancy,
having an affliction for starting setting fires or something
like that. I forget what psychologist, what philosoph
did that. There's going to be a modern thing where there's things
that you've said on the internet and the combination of them
shows who the is like a sociopath.
>> Oh, pyromania. What the is pyromancer? >> Pyromancy
is like magic. >> Oh, control fire with your mind. >> Pyromania.
Yeah. Yeah. >> Yeah. Yeah. Sure.
>> Pyromancers are psychopaths
>> for doing that. Like you, there are some people lit
legitimately that think that I shouldn't be able to pursue my
passions, that I shouldn't have an audience because they disagree
with me on a moral philosophical issue. Like, uh, just the way
he says it, >> that's not moral. That's [__]
up. >> That's incredibly immoral. >> This is one
of the most insanely things I've ever heard. He's flat out saying
that it's bad to judge someone based on their philosophies and
their beliefs, as if people can't have harmful stances on certain
topics. This take sounds like something coming from a legit
Oh, you think it's bad I want to exterminate all Jews? Well,
you're the bigoted one because you're judging me badly as a person
for saying that. And when that logic doesn't persuade people,
Adam brings up other people who have argued for beastiality,
showing confusion as to why those people aren't getting as much
as him. >> Debate Destiny on it, of course, but it wouldn't
be much of a debate because he he agrees with me on that. Have
you ever seen the clips of him talking about the exact same
>> about uh the veganism, the moral consistency thing?
He would definitely agree on the moral consistency thing.
>> I I'm almost positive. Yeah. >> Do you think he
would agree with him on his uh take about lines?
>> No, probably not.
>> Same [__] Of course you haven't because
he's not a furry so people don't share those around the internet.
like he he has the exact same opinion.
If people are going to come at me pretending as if there's anything
malicious about my perspective on it, I would say that applies
more to Destiny than me because his response is literally just
like, "Yeah, animals. They're less species. Whatever. I could
shoot up a room full of cats and not feel anything about it if
I didn't get caught."
That's his that's his opinion on it. So, I don't know how much
of a debate we'd actually >> Huh. I wonder why. Doesn't
>> that mean that he does?
He's saying we wouldn't have a debate on that because Destiny
is like a psychopath and would kittens
if it was legal
>> is that the position Adam's been saying? Cuz I feel
like he's been moraling over like animal abuse. >> Uh moral
frogging at other people over animal abuse. >> Yeah, we
like just discovered he eats >> Although he does say he
does say animal or that he doesn't like animal abuse too in some
some of his Reddit post. >> There's anything malicious
about my perspective on it. I would say that applies more to
Destiny than me because his response is literally just like,
"Yeah, [__] animals. They're less >> Okay.
more than me." So, he's saying like Destiny's response is different
than mine.
>> So, wouldn't he have to have something to disagree with
Destiny about? >> Well, I think he's saying he would disagree,
but it wouldn't be over animals or not animals. >> No,
he goes on to say we wouldn't have much to disagree about. >> Say
that applies more to Destiny than me because his response is
literally so people don't share those around the internet. like
he he has the exact same opinion.
If people are going to come at me pretending as if there's anything
malicious about my perspective on it, I would say that applies
more to Destiny than me because his response is literally just
like, "Yeah, animals. They're less species, whatever. I could
shoot up a room full of cats and not feel anything about it if
I didn't get caught."
That's his that's his opinion on it. So, I don't know how much
of a debate we'd actually have.
He's saying that if you guys think I'm coming at this from a
malicious place, like I don't even like animals or I don't like
care about animals, but that actually applies to Destiny more
than me. So, if that's what you think, we wouldn't have a debate
on the maliciousness part cuz he's more malicious than I am.
>> I think is what he's saying.
>> I wonder why Destiny's degenerate community is defending
his takes on Zuilia, the same community that's currently defending
Destiny for having potential in his possession. >> She's
13 years old now. Oh, dang it. Well, I'm out of here. Goodbye
everyone. >> Adam claims that people are only going after
him because he's a furry. Not >> I just I I kind of get
why you do that. I just a little bit >> not because he's
consistently defending this stuff over the years and gets mad
when you connect the dots. There are people that like really
really want to believe that I'm a bad person and so this is as
close as they get. You >> I'll be real. I and I don't I
don't know if he's a bad person, but I do believe that like probably
someone he knows personally has like a close personal relationship
with or himself, but I have no proof of like the himself part
has like tried to suck a dog or something like 100%. I I feel
like he knows somebody personally that he is like attaching some
of those arguments to where he's like, I don't think you should
go to jail for this. I think it's a victimless crime. But uh
>> Yeah, I feel like that has to be the case. I I don't
know if it would be him. Mostly because he seems to be like somebody
who would probably
just say that possibly. Like he doesn't seem like somebody who
goes, "Oh, because I know how the social conventions are, I know
I shouldn't talk about this." He seems like somebody who's like,
"No, if I think something if I think something's true, I'll just
say >> I'm going to be real. If I find out that someone
I know personally,
like they come to me and they let me know that they suck the
dog's dick and they're like worried or something or
I'm probably I'm taking mushrooms the next day and I'm just going
to try to figure out what went wrong with my life. >> Yeah.
Yeah.
>> You know, >> I'm like at a wrong end or something.
>> I ended up near the wrong people. I'm >> I'm not
like taking advantage of people. I'm not like abusing anybody.
I'm not like being a massive to people or like stealing money
or anything. It's literally just like
it's literally just oh this guy has an opinion on something and
I disagree with that opinion and I'm going to get very emotional
about this person's opinion and try to try to present it in a
way where I can connect the dots and it's no
you wouldn't want to get off my higher being if if the uh oh
what are they called? If the mind flarers ever actually come
around. Okay, technically you can't consent with a mind flare.
It's like a It's like a 500 IQ being,
>> like
I have never seen the movie John Wick, but apparently that dog
meant enough for that to go everybody.
>> Like I I think about my cat and if somebody did anything
to hurt my cat, I'm like I would start crying just thinking about
somebody hurting my cat.
>> Yeah. I think there's some
there's like humanity missing from your body if you do not give
a [__] about animals.
>> If you can't imagine an animal that you would be concerned
about. >> Yeah. Absolutely. 100%. >> I deeply care
about animals and I couldn't at all imagine wanting to one. So
what the is wrong with this guy?
>> Yeah. I don't I don't know. I would love to know more
about how he got brought up. I guess I
like was this a thing since he was like a child since he first
watched Lion King. He was like, "Oh, this has changed me entirely
cuz I don't know. I don't know, man. I don't know. Longer just
an opinion. No, this is actual abuse from his words, right? >> I
think connecting the dots can be very valid sometimes. Using
Vosch as an example again, not only has he consistently defended
and lolli, but he was also found to have lollycon on his computer.
What? And recently, someone leaked DMs showing Vosch sending
inappropriate messages to a minor. I think it's fair to connect
all those things together and claim Vosch is a I'm not trying
to say that Adam is as bad as the funny thing about that is is
I think people are like, "Oh, it's it's like good to put all
that together." He says it like, "It's good to put all that together
and call this guy." And in my head I'm like, "Yeah, but if he
like argue if he was like somebody you liked, I don't think you'd
do that. I think you'd understand keeping the things separate.
I think it's just like you probably make that argument only with
people you dislike where you put all the dots together like that.
>> Um not to say you couldn't with Vosch or that like you
shouldn't be concerned about Vosch in like certain ways, but
I think I think probably most of these people when they say,
"Oh, put the dots together like that." It's cuz they don't like
this guy and they want to [__] with him with Vos
specifically like I want to call you a is basically what this
guy's saying. Like I don't >> Do you make a distinction?
Do you make a distinction between lolli enjoyers and
>> Yeah. Yeah.
a big difference between it being drawn and it being like a real
tangible thing in the world to me. >> I think it's like
bad. >> I think there are people who know better than to
say that than to be Mr. Girl. Again, I think there are people
that know better than to say what Mr. Girl
>> And then Loi, is there a socially acceptable version
of it on the
>> Yeah, I see what you're saying. So, I would say that
like you could be sus that like it's just a way of like >> but
it's also like all of Japanese culture is like weird around that.
Like >> permanently sus. I think I'm just permanently sus
and I don't trust any of these people. And the moment that I
say, "Oh, yeah, that guy's not a in a year, he will have like
10 children or something just to humiliate me." >> I I
understand that feeling sometimes. Okay. I keep watching it happen
to Connor over and over again. like it's uh >> rough life
out there. there's some some weird cosmic force at play that
just like every time he's like okay this is the I can finally
stop defending now and then like actually you hear that this
guy just confirmed he sent child or sorry that he retained child
born he's
>> not again >> not extreme dad
I hear what's happening with you in 5 years so >> not good
Vos pondered the orb and he saw extreme dad's future I pray I
pray Vos never knows who I am Okay, I never want to know my future.
>> Defy the odds, extreme dad. >> Wait, wait, hold
on. Billy Joe Bush, are you asking us that or are you saying
someone else is doing that? No longer covering politics, too.
Oh, you talk about the destiny thing with Connor where he's like
Connor's like, "Please don't stop. Please don't. I've done everything
I could to keep you in this. Please don't stop." >> Yeah,
that was a that was a rough one.
>> He couldn't be the hero now. He's lost his hero. Really
sucks for that guy.
>> Yeah. All right, we got Dude, we actually have a lot
more Yms content. I've gota We got to keep powering through.
We got
>> Oh, hold on,
>> bro. His first bite proves YMS doesn't eat it as oft
doesn't eat it often for >> You can try zooming in
>> to this piece. >> Is that Dude, somebody get him
the pills. Somebody Somebody get him the pills now. Hold on.
>> Why'd he do that? >> I don't eat steak often.
Somebody Oh, yeah. There you go. >> But it's good.
Thank you. It was delicious. >> You know what sucks? I
thought of like three questions while I was over there and I
get somebody get Adam the prescription stat. Okay, somebody get
the prescription stat.
>> It's rough, dude. It's rough watching him eat that steak
right there. >> He's still showing a repeated pattern of
behavior where he's offending deplorable while at the same time
pretending like it's a philosophical debate in order to evade
criticism. What really ties this all together is Adam's bizarre
obsession with Scar, the main villain of Disney's The Lion King.
He loves Scar so much that he's commissioned someone to draw
his persona, caressing the of an anthropomorphic scar. Even we
commissioned someone to draw his persona, caressing the of an
anthropomorphic scar. So he commissioned someone to draw his
persona, the female horse persona, and then
it's grabbing the scar, an anthropomorphized
scar. Even weirder are a full set of drawings he commissioned
showing a non-bipedal scar getting in the by yes these exist
and can be found on his notsafe for work Twitter accounts not
safe for work ad furry account of Adam Horsey fur affinity.net/
/ user/adom.
Why would you have this out in the open? Why wouldn't you just
live your your furry life
Like that is that starts to get to the point where I'm like,
yeah, you like the >> Why
why did we allow Trump to so broadly say Antifa is the terrorist
group? We could have hyperfocused in on the
>> that shooter was doing online furry. >> Well,
yeah, he appeared to be. Uh was it the the video game? the furry
gay video >> I'm I think in the future there will be a
correlation with mass shootings or gun violence and furries.
>> I mean, yeah, could fies I feel like furries more than
trans people have like a tendency to be like more like and I
think there could be some kind of trend >> somehow Tylenol
in the womb. >> we know this now. >> Yeah, we do.
That's true. Anyway, we got to get them their anti- autism pills
growing up or we'll have a lot more fries out here taking shots.
>> Force feed him folic acid. >> These exist and
can be found on his not safe for work Twitter account. This man
jerks it to gay lion. It's all even weirder when you remember
how many times Adam has stated that he's only attracted to furries.
>> If I was a zoo pile, I'd straight up say it. I'm borderline
stupid with what I'll admit to. But here's a little something
to help you out just in case you're confused. Would bang. Would
not bang. Would bang. would not bang. >> How does the like
that clip right there
>> Does that just mean this guy is not cuz he is showing
you pictures of real life things and then showing you a cartoon
like a drawing? >> Oh, this gets brought up later in the
video, too. Um, well, he's saying anthropomorphized, so he would
the things in fursuits, too. >> Yeah, which is why he has
the fursuit.
>> Big big >> stop. I you know how much I love The
Lion King.
>> I love The Lion. I love all of the early Disney movies.
And you're >> to know that Adam Yms has a life-sized version
of Scar. Lifesized.
>> Be prepared.
>> This excuse work when you're attracted to a >> begging
Shadman to draw him. Okay, but when are you guys going to draw
and anime 4K images of my horse persona getting railed in the
by Scar from the Lion King? May 25th, 2017.
May 25th, 2017.
A day that will live in infamy. >> A cartoon lion. >> All right.
Who wants to watch Lion King with me after stream in the Discord?
>> He loves Scar for his personality, not because he's
a lion. >> Like, if I fall in love with a character, I'm
literally falling in love with a character. Like the actual character.
I wouldn't be attracted to the design of Scar from the Lion King
if he didn't have the same voice or mannerisms or anything like
that. Like, it's all still there in the same way that it would
be if you're a human being.
But it's really difficult for people to like rationalize things
that they don't understand. I don't know why, but this sounds
like something you'd hear from a safe, sleazy nice guy. He's
into scar for his personality, I guess. But you see, according
to Adam, it's perfectly fine for someone to be attracted to cartoon
animals. He even used this thing called the Harkness test to
justify it. And if you don't know what that is, it's a test ranking
how
are with non-human entities. For context of this next clip, Ana
brought up the female white cat from the Aristocrats. >> It's
like a Marilyn Monroe type voice. >> Oh, is that like a
small kitten?
>> No, it's like a mom cat. I'm just trying to figure out
why it's wrong. >> Well, cuz >> it passes the harness
test. >> Yeah, it Yeah. >> What's a harness test?
>> We've never heard of the harness test. Okay, so people
now that we are in the age of like everybody's just attracted
to weird. That's like just actually there's a fake age. There
was a fake age that didn't come about. It turns out in a in a
in an insane case of mass pranking, okay, everybody got convinced
that oh all deviency is normal now. And then there was like a
5year period where people came and outed themselves and now we
just spend the next like 15 years mocking all of those people
until >> Yeah. It's actually the same it is the same hundred
people that keep making different accounts that are yas queening
all of you degenerates. >> Yeah. Yeah. And now we it's
all out there and now you're going to be mocked for it forever.
So unlucky. Unlucky. >> Just all like fictional like dragons,
right? Um, so now there's the debate over like, okay, is it ethical
to like be attracted to this thing? So like some random person
like I don't know if their name was Hark or something, but furries
and like a No, it's Harkness is the captain from Firefly, right?
That aliens. Isn't that who Harkness is?
>> Harkness test. Hold on. It's like Jim Harkness or something.
Jack Harkness.
Doc Doctor Who is Jack Harkness. Okay, Doctor Who. Most other
online communities that like talk about fictional porn or whatever
have generally accepted this where the harness test is like okay
is this creature
of adult age for that creature in I am not a fake fan of Firefly.
I don't like Firefly. I've never Sorry, I don't not like Firefly.
I've never seen Firefly.
I just thought it was the guy. I thought that was the guy's name.
You never ever heard me claim to be a fan of
And are they able to communicate with you on a level
>> in that is you know like uh equivalent to like English
or whatever >> right and like these different standards.
It's like >> this is okay this is not okay and it's generally
accepted. So >> yeah no it's fair >> kind of funny.
>> Oh yes it's valid to any animal if you deem it intelligent
enough. I couldn't expect a better take from the guy who dresses
up as a horse in a skirt. the degenerate only fans model with
tattoos on every inch of her body and her husband. His hardcore
fans are well aware of his attraction to Scar and have turned
it into a community meme. It got so parasocial that these fans
raised $1,000 to get Adam a life-siz Scar doll, which he received.
>> In the mail only a month ago. >> Guys, I've actually
don't have anything like that. I couldn't even
>> Not very long.
It's a very short it's a very short tale.
>> I agree. >> Since people are undoubtedly
>> He claims He claims he made no such hole. He claims
no hole was made. Okay. Do not do not add a hole that he didn't
add. Okay. This kind of [__] up from you guys. >> Conspiracy
theories. There's no hole in the back. >> Do not hole.
>> It would be in the front duh to put the dragon toy in.
>> There's no holes anywhere.
so yeah, this his >> I don't mind his fans joking about
this, but I'm laughing at him, not with him. I'm not going to
definitively say that Adam wants to real animals, but I can't
exactly fault someone for thinking that. All this stuff put together
paints a really disturbing picture, but not enough people seem
to really know about the stuff. So, I wanted to talk about it.
I used to be a fan of this guy, and I still think it's fine to
>> What's up? There might not be a hole, but you don't
need to include a hole for you to put a strap on on a stuffed
>> That's true. >> Which is probably what he's doing
it for. It's like you're going to be a bad dragon one, too.
>> Why do you know about >> Why do I know about
the internet for more than 5 years? >> Oh, okay.
>> Those are the really expensive fancy ones. They >> They're
like animal ones. >> Unicorn shapes. >> Yeah. They're
like animal dicks. >> There videos. But for me at least,
I'm not going to be able to look at them the same way again.
Like when watching his Lion King videos, there will always be
a voice at the back of my mind telling me that he likes the movie
not just because it's good, but because he goons really hard
to